well the daily infection rate according  to one medical expert serves as a good  reminder that we are still not  out of the woods from the pandemic  getting vaccinated still remains the  best choice  and i would certainly encourage and  recommend everyone to get their vaccine  if they haven't yet  um it doesn't mean a hundred percent  like i said  despite uh how good they are um they're  not 100 productive you can still get  covert  19 but your chances of getting very sick  or ending up in the hospital  are very very low well we spoke to dr a  peg shot desai  and who tells us that covet 19 is still  very contagious  she's reminding everyone to keep the  hand sanitizer close by  and the face masks on to get the best  protection  even if you are fully vaccinated we also  spoke about the new variants and why  people shouldn't ignore them  we will have more on that coming up at  six o'clock